this is the cube fanatics war zone
raided 98 players
1761 average rating time handicapped 30
minutes of one-minute chess or
approximately one minute chest double
those points they beat me to it
get over here clock be good to me French
we know our Fort Knox Fort Knox
okay let's come over here I shouldn't
even back that Bishop up okay get in the
center I'm on this point the Knights
gonna get kicked away he's getting
kicked away he's trapped no he's not
it's box him out to protect this pond in
an end game who stands better let's come
over here lock down on that pond why is
this so positional let's hang on to this
and what's going on here I know get my
rook my bishop here guard this pawn like
that and now target this pawn
he's not going anywhere okay now I could
take him if I took it too soon
now let's go here sneaky stuff sneaky
stuff sneaky stuff this is leading to
Maine can you believe that
whoa back to tournament bunch of two's
that was a tight game that was a really
tight game all right here we go
Sicilian no matter what oh it's been a
while since I went fishing let's see
let's see about that here we go ah my
pony isn't moving if you don't move I
don't know what to say
tongue-tied variation b5 there should be
seven what is going on with the Queen
she's in rough shape now rough shape pin
City might have a quick resigner even on
time no don't be an odd mover anything
but an on mover do we have an odd mover
here I think we might have an on mover
no we have a mover I'll take the Queen
don't get fancy don't try to get fancy
just play fast this game isn't even
gonna end it's not ending because of
what it's not ending because of actually
let's do this instead it's not going to
end because my opponents have any time
any time making one threat bishops
falling by force that's the only move to
save the day for just a moment back to
tournament six six six six three and a
bunch twos striker he's up there he's
got one of the he's up there with six
stay focused come on Mouse treat me well
Knight he was gonna kill me get out of
there get out my queen us to run home Oh
scary
um I'm um
let's go here I gotta get rid of this
guy he's way too tough oh I think there
was something really good for my
opponent I think it was missed Knight
takes here I think would have killed me
with Queen coming down to age 4 Oh would
have been bad news bad news
alright let's go here let's come here
night there okay well that's sad story I
have to babysit upon not fun I also have
to get out of a pin
c'mon rook defend put pressure on f7
they can't be too happy about defending
f7 yes
they're afraid yes they're afraid
come on Knight run away Knight take this
pine I get the Queen o tricks everywhere
I'm on the night as well uh-oh he takes
here now that's not working that can't
work does it work no it doesn't work I
got the knight discovered tricks on the
clean and now it's pile up on what what
am I even piling up on rook takes here
oh I could take here safely right I
better be could take that please defend
is it defendable could shaking my queen
actually alright cuz I was dropping the
rook at the end of that back to
tournament 12:12 12/12 okay let's go
here I can't read this guy's name the
them
damn I gotta play against them I say
that all the time anyhow I take a lot of
slack flora - why do you why do you call
your opponent them or their Oh what's
going on here that's a free pawn isn't
it I'm getting kicked around a bit here
we go
here we go nice and easy nice and easy
support your Center here we go Castle
open up that f5 huh
whoa let's I was fearful Bishop here I
had fear of that particular move it may
still happen if I'm not careful
oh let me take that guy I don't he's
just a giant thorn get rid of the giant
thorns f7 f7 chop here whoa
I'm just gonna take care Knight takes
would have been maybe good to pig I have
a pig here another pig clean here that
can't be right can it
this has to be good crashing turn on
this point huh where's my time where's
my time my time go is this working whoa
I only have three oh no no no no no no
no no no I have to dodge checks and
stuff no wait here Oh how'd I do that
time I'm losing my breath Jay fish ah I
need the time to start flashing or
something what distracted me in that
game what was I so aah my pony was just
moving fast or what I don't that those
are not those are never on purposes
don't ever start thinking purpose I
don't and I'll do that stuff on purpose
there goes my light-square bishop he was
such a good guy too
no no not really well maybe if I got in
at 5:00 anyhow Bishop d2 stop night
before stuff my rook is an idiot ah what
an idiot over here a to seen better days
let's do this I guess I don't even know
what it's doing what okay I don't know
why exactly I moved my king there I am
Wow my nights are getting a workout a
lot of fun here Oh
pawn push okay let's take okay the queen
is gonna be in some trouble
the bishop gonna take let's get rid of
it where does my knight wanna live age
six
tricky age six
forks know they're not gonna take that
got the rook
let's lock down on that pond for a
second
let's lock down on this no more pawn
breaks stay active with the Queen rook
has to come over to c8
it didn't come over to no I'm not gonna
take their it gets e2 after that now
it's a threat no it's not over here 17
no I don't have 17 they have 17 oh come
on over here nice and cozy over here
pawn push stop that rip from getting
active that's the plan
no activity rook over here take a pawn
hit the bishop next whoa
that's I'm up a rook pigs some pigs
where's my time don't tell me I'm gonna
lose on time don't let it be stalemate
no no no no no no no no no no they're
gonna tell you why where's my clock
going where's my clock going I got that
one but my clock is like what is going
on am i starting off with just way too
little time ah yeah just keep
complaining about the time just complain
about the time you complainer that's how
you do you play bullet chess and you
just complain about your clock I just
move faster you idiot
I could hear now okay let's trade Queens
maybe I'll have an easier time if the
Queens are off get those Queens off the
board maybe you could do better without
the Queens
no no no no no no no no no oh oh man I
just dropped upon for no good reason at
all because of a stupid Mouse oh I have
a wounded mouse like you haven't you
have no idea how wounded my mouse is oh
is he wounded oh man okay I have to
defend against Knight c7 stuff oh man I
should probably take a pond no I had a
fork to worry about is he gonna play
here now pigs um ii
fear the pigs they're dangerous there's
one that's all you need oftentimes now
the night is jumping into holes I just
drop upon it stopping another pod oh
it's better work it's better work my
beep on he's trying to hold up for pawns
come on save the day
f pon keep going come on King be a
fighter
get out of there night ok stay active oh
I'm on the rook I was in check though
I'm on the rook mates happening one two
three one two three mate one two and
then three coming up unavoidable back to
tournament 42
whoa 56:45 42 who's that
free chessmen I got a catch free
chessmen a lot of time left 18 minutes
and change more Grand Prix alright let's
go here stay focused now hang on
move fast otherwise you're gonna be
complaining again backup bishop Queen g3
f5 Bishop h6 stuff maybe all right
Knight takes ok let's stop that one hang
on to that Bishop he's a good guy Queen
g3 g3 f5 Bishop h6 stuff it's happening
there might be 9 h5 but Queen g4 piles
up on this guy catching up on time this
is a good thing
let's go Bishop is going to actually I'm
not going to play Bishop h6 of Ponte so
I'll go Knight here to have 5 that's a
better idea they're chewing up a lot of
time uh-oh
less than 25
ooh let's get rid of it no just play
here well well this game isn't even
gonna end there's no time I don't want
any of my clock to burn I'm gonna pre
move no matter what and do that and this
no matter what I don't want my clock to
tick and this I'm not even gonna
recapture and this okay back to terminus
72 72 61 56 - ahead of me ah just barely
in confetti land 16 minutes and change
remaining I got a play against the chess
champ chess champ won I need a Oh going
for a scholars main golfer the killer
scholars me Oh killed the Queen hit a
bishop block a check Oh
kitchen sink I'm getting kitchen synced
here I'm getting kitchen sink or kitchen
sink everywhere rooks following bishops
falling nights falling more nights
getting captured come on where's the
main don't know no fry me whatever you
do just resign come on is that me not
where's me just move they're gonna move
there a non mover no they're not they're
mover that's I needed that yes who's up
there 72 72 tie for first don't count me
out don't count me out
come on let's go precious seconds oh
okay let's go here it's a little
uncomfortable well I'm gonna take that
two minor pieces two minor pieces are
better than the rook in most cases yeah
well two minor pieces is often better
than a rook in a pond
that's is my opponent doesn't have a
pioneer in here so I think Bishop here
probably Knight our Bishop here or
something is probably good ah she just
removed that night oh it's it's a
freebie night at 596 incoming giant
piece right here on e6 brutal Oh
everything's getting hit right now we
take this rook and then come over here
where is the mate Queen here looking for
mate next g7 is the threat Queen g7
clean check on g5 the Queen goes to H
mate next back to tournament ninety doc
I want again ninety ninety eighty one
less than less than fifteen remaining no
no no no caro-kann H pond let's just
just take that out they're not taking it
I want to get rid of the light square
bishop this is not the best way to do
that though I need support in the center
I want the light scrub issues to come
off oh okay this could be good though my
knight has taken the light square bishop
comes to life might want to take like
that defend my knight break this pin
I want my knight to be captured and I
want to be able to recapture with my
pawn so that's why I'm going here I want
the light square bishop come off and I
want to be able to mate on g2 you put
pressure on this night actually I could
have won a pawn right there let's let's
go for right now this Knight is caught
in a crossfire hit twice
defendant zero
I'm just gonna take like that I'm not
100% sure why gonna go like this and
then maybe get a pin going on that
wasn't a good idea by me I should just
take him in a different way
lack of better words in a different way
okay here we go get these lights great
bishops off please
main threat they're defending drop the
King up oh I don't want to have to see
that move over here get active clock
situation don't go there and drop your
Queen Queen trade me that okay the rook
is kind of uh it's kind of dead now pick
this guy up and then move my beep on in
get my beep on rolling push let's kick
this king away first let's take care and
then push another down back to
tournament back to chairman 110 110 I
have a lead on tiebreaks if it comes
down to that oh this guy's up there he
has 77 77 points I'm gonna start going
seed 3 why have I been doing the Grand
Prix so much ok this is a winner are we
in a war time I'm gonna try this oh they
missed that Queen trade I'm on uh they
got Forks if you don't go for a Queen
trade you have to take that and take
this pond they get this no they don't
their night is dead I should have maybe
taken the night it's support my night if
I could only move stop c5 I'm playing up
a piece here I gotta get pushed around a
piece is scaring me the most
all right this move is maybe the
scariest let's come here put pressure on
this pawn deter this advance let's come
back it's probably gonna get kicked away
anyhow and now let's grab this pine I'm
on b7 time situation Bishop here I think
I could kick it away let's kick it away
I just want to grab that beep on even if
I have to give that guy
stay on the seventh let's kick that
bishop away Bishop here maybe I'm
dropping this okay keep pressure on that
Bishop okay I got a defend against
checks oh man this is scary you take
that and then this I got I'll stop a
piece right here and I have this covered
my nights watching over for this rooks
are coming off and okay let's go tonight
how can I keep this really simple
I need my King to start playing let's do
this first jump over here get my king
active my king active again and now get
my rook behind my pawn and then push it
away okay now we start pushing push push
push
oh I dropped my knight they don't have
any time though back to tournament 135
130 I what though they lost a game or no
is that a different guy that's a
different guy striker is now up there ah
okay I have a good center let's go each
pawn who does that move playing they're
gonna play that oh are they gonna castle
castle
that would be a bad move don't castle
white whatever you do oh the queen is
dead then I resign right here just take
the Queen right there's the only move I
think I back up I think it's best to
just back up they can resign let's back
up on the Queen twice and the knight
twice now I take this queenside castle
and then pawn push I'm on the Queen I'll
back up if the knight hits my Bishop
let's back up here first
Queen's trapped if she takes my pawn I'm
gonna do this anyhow clean trade right
here I'm on d2 at the end of this okay
coming up that rook is trapped now I
back up
I got the bishop and soon the rook has
to take my bishop there didn't take my
bishop got the night kitchen sink they
here where is that mate
one two three one two right here
unavoidable back to tournament 150 no oh
I only have 150 170 155 8 minutes and
change ah eight minutes
oh man how many games did I have in I
don't have any time to see Bishop c4 I'm
trying them
where are the quick weapons I need a
quick win d3 night here if there's like
a night move to one of those two let's
break at the center of it alright let's
break this open night here a play night
here let's do it now watch out for mates
against this point
don't fall for me whatever you do just
Queen check or even bishop check let's
go with the Queen check pawn push I can
maybe take here mmm no oh there's a fork
here no I can take probably okay let's
get rid of this Queen take me to threat
or something very close to that is this
mate move King move to b8 bishop has to
back up pre move that
right don't know just resign just be
resigning her designing six minutes and
change six minutes and change I better
just pre move that it's not me the King
can actually run away Bishop here Queen
takes the king runs away so I guess it
could have been worse
six minutes in 35 seconds remaining back
determent 170 190 I got to get that guy
no two guys ahead of me one on tiebreaks
the assassin is well aware of my sneaky
stuff here it's definitely well aware oh
man I'm gonna get pushed around
definitely gonna get pushed around okay
okay I get um there's a structural
problem here for white let's do that Oh
bishop here is probably good dropping
stuff I think alright let's let's just
defend that I want to get rid of the
LightSquared bishop s' pawn push I
should I had that earlier pawn push pawn
push I get to f4 maybe let's come over
here why did I go there let's trade off
a pair of rooks maybe my bishops want to
guard all entry points maybe okay let's
stop the knight from getting active now
now I'm Knight right here I'm opening up
the dark squares I think I want to keep
this though ah let's get over here clean
here I really don't want to have to do
that let's come over here
clean takes it's a good pose for my
queen my knight wants to do something
else no I want my rook on g6 no that's
not happening
what's my knight even doing over here
Knight
this is where you want to play I have
discovered and I'm gonna play here even
though I'm dropping upon well I better
do this now
what's the clock situation
let's just rate cleans behind push there
down on time there down on time what to
throw - 30 - 30 190 well how do you come
back against - 30 there's only four
minutes left four minutes and change and
I'm two games out wow what is that part
up to get that Bishop out of here I want
to get on f5 okay now they can't Castle
no castling Oh quick resign you know you
want to resign please please this is
what I need
yes back to tournament - 10 to 30 - 10
am I gonna get paired up with that guy
it's possible he'd probably still be not
on tiebreaks though let's go
can I sneak in two more games two more I
didn't want to do that melt more mouse
slips in action I probably can't take it
even if pawn push because eventual Queen
84 make up your mind take the knight or
what what's the story make up your mind
I miss pond twice pawn push pawn push
break it down break it down break down
that structure take with the Queen
Queens come off this is not gonna be a
quick win at all I'm gonna pre move that
and I was gonna go there anyhow with
insurance now that one's with insurance
that Bishop over here Bishop grab a pond
and just come back defend stuff
King here no matter what Knight fork
that's a bad move actually that was
probably the worst move to make right
there oh wait a pre move well done
Knight check he's gonna haunt you again
no I got the knight in the corner run
poniard past and you're fast
dr. Seuss mode here we go watch out for
the past and the fast puns I'm on the
rook I missed it
we're both blundering in this one
Bishop's coming off run Pond run Pond
you're fast
keep running take a bishop he's free now
they resigned back determine 2:30
I believe that guy back to 32:28 that's
what I need first-place confetti come on
I have time for just one more
don't you dare give up don't you dare
give up open Sicilian everybody loves
the open Sicilian
let's go Bishop Bishop d3 castle run F
pun over here I want to get to this
square since its weakened my Knights
cannot can do that let's make this guy
flinch is he gonna move to reinforce my
night if take side to go like that let's
go f4 open it up I have a what do I have
I have a lead in development come on
let's go one minute 33 I want to get at
f7 no matter what let's go here
wait a five-night h5 let's get rid of
that night I'm on em 7 twice and to take
rook up and over now let's stop knight
here that's gonna be problem one-minute
aid I have to get this game in I don't
have anything else
take here I'm on the night I'm on h7
take the night you know you want to take
the night you know you want to move the
night yes you did mine on 1987 that's me
to 52-28 that guy can't catch me come on
just let the clock tick tick tick tick
come let's go to 52 28 to 13 can I sneak
in another one just to make sure there's
no back to back with designers happening
I'm on the Queen come on go go go 35
seconds
get out of there Knight give a check
they must be scared they're thinking
bring the Queen out 25 ticks right here
forks forks happening on c2 18 seconds
remaining okay I can't do anything scrap
here castle jump over here push your
pawn in the center come on just I want
the clock to run out just call it call
the tournament called the tournament
call it it says completed couple beds
Carla don't make me play this for now
Khalid
yes comfortin what is it what is it what
is it what is it yes take it first place
confetti like Islip table whoa
let's see oh man
250 he won that one too right at the end
two fifty two forty eight to thirteen
209 man the games are Wow